ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เจอกันคลิปที่ 2 นะคะอ่าของวันนี้วันนี้
วันอะไรนะคะครูเรียมวันนี้เดี๋ยววัน
อาทิตย์
วันวันไข่ได้ค่ะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์นะคะเห็นได้
ไหมคะได้ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะมันอาทิตย์วันที่
14 ไหมคะ
วันที่
14 ค่ะ 14 เดือน 7  18  19  44 พากย์ดี
เดือนเดือนอะไรคะครูเรียมเดือน
พฤศจิกายนอ่าเดือน
พฤศจิกายนนะคะให้ค่ะ
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือนที่
11 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะ 5 ตี
คศอะไรคะพี่ข้อศ.
2521 ขอ 2,000  21 ท้ายค่ะปี
พศ.ราคะปีพตอะไรใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะปีพต
2564 ค่ะนี้พ.ศ
2506  14 ชัยค่ะ 555
1564 นะคะวันอาทิตย์เวลาค่ะครูเรียมตอน
นี้ถ้าตอนนี้กี่โมงกูเห็นดูอุ้ยตบ
โทรศัพท์ตก
กี่โมงคะครูเอ๋ตอนนี้
11:00 น
51 ค่ะ
11:51 นะคะ
[เพลง]
ร้อนแล้วนะ
ร้อนของเรียมเย็นสบายบ้านครูเอ๋ร้อน
x ดิบแลหมาตัว f ปิดมีมีแอร์แล้วกูเอกก็
ปิดแอร์ก็ร้อนนิดหน่อยโอเคเอกก็เปิดเปิด
แอร์ไม่เป็นไรช่อ
หน้าร้อน
โอเคเหตุ 5
11:51 นาทีงั้นไปค่ะเราก็ต้องพูดเสร็จ
เป็นเวลากี่โมงนะคะ
คลิปนี้เราพูด 30 นาที 30 นาทีนะคะก็จะ
พูดเสร็จตอน
เที่ยงเที่ยง
21 นาทีน
เที่ยงใช่ค่ะ 21 นาทีนะใช่แล้ว
ครูเรียม
เตรียมพูดพูดเนี่ยคลิปที่แล้วเนี่ย
ค่ะคิดที่แล้ว 30 นาทีใช่ไหม
คลิปที่แล้ว
40 นาทีอ่ะ
เนื้อเพลงตี Map โคเรียมกับครูเอ๋ต้องพูด
30 นาที
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงพูดพูดๆลืมเวลา
ใช่ลืมดูเวลา
งั้นแม่ก็เปลี่ยนเป็น 40 นาทีนะคะ
ตกใจนะคะอ่ะอ่ะพูดพูดนานๆ
ขอคอค่ะนิคอ
นครภาษาไทยพูดคอแห้งคอให้คอแห้งเวลาพูด
สวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณพูดนาน 40 นาทีก็
ขอแห้ง
เสียงไม่บายถ้า
หิวน้ำไหมคะหิวค่ะหิวน้ำดื่มน้ำค่ะคุณ
เรียมโอเคเองมีน้ำเปล่า
น้ำเปล่าอยู่ในไหนคะ
น้ำเปล่าอยู่ไหนขวดไหมคะขวดใช่มั้ยขวดอ่ะ
เวลาเดี๋ยวๆกูเลียมผู้เตรียมกำลังทำอะไร
กำลังเปิดมือใช่ไหมคะเบอร์มือไปจับจับ
อะไรคะฝาอ่าฝาอ่าฝาขวดใช่มะไฟข่าวขวดน้ำ
ฝาไทยค่ะกับแล้วทำอะไรคะแล้วก็หมุนหมุนนะ
คะหมุน
หมุนแล้วก็เปิด
ใช่ค่ะแก้วไหมคะเคไหมคะไม่มีค่ะๆ
ว่าผู้ที่ดื่ม
ดื่มจากขวดใช่ไหมคะอ่าได้ค่ะดื่มจากขวด
คุณคุณพ่อคุณแม่
พูดไม่ได้พูดมั้ยคะพ่อกับแม่ไม่อยู่ขอให้
กู a นะก็ชอบน้ำแล้วก็หมกมือจับแล้วก็
หมุนเปิดขวดแล้วก็
ดื่มจากขวด 5
8 เวลาคู๋เด็กๆอ่ะ
พ่อแม่
พี่สาวแม่คุณแม่เดี๋ยวคุย Share  screen
นิดนึงนะคะ
มี
มีคุณมีพ่อ
แม่ไหม O
O  O  A
AB ก็จะมีพี่ชาย
งูพี่สาว
น้องชายอย่าแล้วก็แม่แม่เนี่ยมีพี่สาว
ซุปเปอร์มาเฟีย
พี่สาวคุณแม่
[เพลง]
ดุนะกูเอน้ำมีน้ำจากขวดเปิดแล้วก็ดื่ม
คุณคุณคุณป้า
ขอ
ป๊ะไม่ได้
คุณป้าบอกไม่ได้มีเอาน้ำมาเปิดขวด
เอ้อใช่มั้ยเปิดฝาอันเนี้ยเปิดพูดเปิดฝา
ฝาหรือเปิดขวดโอเคนะคะแล้วก็ดื่ม
คุณป้า
คุณป้าบอกไม่ได้
ต้องมีแก้ว
อ๋อ
แล้วก็
เฮเพน้ำ
เทน้ำลงแก้วแล้วก็ดื่มเงิน
คุณป้าไม่อยู่โอเคขวดอ่ะคุณป้าอยู่แก้วขอ
ตอนนี้โอเคแม่ก็บอกแม่ก็บอก
ไม่ดีพ่อก็บอกไม่โอเค
ครูเอ๋บอกพอดี
โรงเรียมก็คิดเหมือนครูเอ๋ใช่เลยค่ะให้
ค่ะ So  dame ก็คิดเหมือนครูเอ๋
นักเรียนราคะเวลาดื่มน้ำนักเรียนดื่มน้ำ
เปิดฝาชนะเปิดฝาขวดแล้วก็ดื่มอันนี้
A5  b
k น้ำใส่แก้ว
เราก็ดื่มแล้วก็หยิบแก้วดื่มกูเองไม่แก้ว
ก็ได้
อันนี้ไม่
ได้แล้วเทน้ำใส่แก้วแล้วก็ดื่ม
ถ้วยนะช่วยช้าง่างั้นเนี่ยนักเรียนอะไรคะ
ay  ay  ay น่ะอ้ะแต่เดิมจะขวด
อะไร a  b
เดิมจากแก้ว a
ดื่มจากขวด
คูเรียมอยากรู้มั้ยนักเรียนหนึ่งที่ไหน
อยากรู้ค่ะน่ารักเห็นช่วยพิมพ์ค่ะมาด้าน
ล่างนะคะว่า a หรือ B ใช่นะลล์หรือ B
อันนี้เป็นน้ำเปล่าใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครู
เรียมดื่มน้ำอัดลมไหมคะดื่มค่ะน้ามันโดน
น้ำอัดลมนี้ครูเรียมดื่มอะไรคะโค้กเป๊ป
ทีมกับไอซ์
โค้ก 5 กูเรียมดื่มโค้กนะคะอุ้ยว่างให้
เสื้อโค้กสีอะไรสีดำใช่ไหมไทยค่ะก็มีขวด
โค้กมีแบบขวด
ใช่ไหมค่ะแบบนี้ป่ะ
ใช่ค่ะครูเอกก็วาดไม่สวยนะโคล่า
แล้วก็ข้างในเป็น
ใช่ค่ะสีดำ
สีดำนิดหน่อย
แล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะครูเอ๋ดื่มน้ำอัดลมในค่ะ
รู้เองไม่ค่อยชอบอากูเอไม่ค่อยชอบดื่มน้ำ
อัดลมนั้นนั่งน้ำอัดลมก็จะมีอีกมีโค้ก
เป๊ปซี่สไปรท์แฟนต้าอาคูลิมเวลาเรียมผู้
ริมชอบโค้งใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมีผู้เรียนชอบโค้ก
แล้วเวลาดื่มโค้กน่ะโค้กจะมีแบบแบบขวด
แล้วก็จะมีแบบ
กระป๋อง
งู
[เพลง]
แบบกระป๋อง
คู่เรียม
ชอบชอบแบบไหนคะช็อปแบบขวด
เรียมชอบแบบขวดอ๋อแม่ไม่ชอบแบบกระป๋องไม่
ค่ะ
แล้วอ้าเตรียมเปิดขวดดื่ม
เตรียมดื่มไม่หมดฮ่าๆลืมก็ปิดฝาค่ะ
ใช่แล้วก็เปิดตู้เย็นค่ะเข้าตู้เย็น
เดี๋ยวกูเลี้ยงกูเอกคิดจะถ้าพ่อคูณเลี่ยม
ดื่มโค้กเนี่ยดื่มจากขวดหรือว่าใส่แก้ว
งู
อร์ดดื่มจากขวดเรื่องจากขวด
คูเรียมไม่ใส่น้ำแข็งเหรอคะ
น้ำแข็ง
ขอ
เย็นๆ
ข้า
ฆ่าโค้กไม่เห็นโค้งไม่เย็นเห็นก็จะเทใส่
น้ำแข็งอ๋อ
แต่ถ้าโค้งใส่ตู้เย็น
ใช่มีตู้เย็นนะคะๆตู้เย็น
มีตู้เย็นแล้วคู่เตรียมเอาโค้กใส่ตู้เย็น
เรามีมีตู้เย็นเอาโค้กใส่ตู้เย็นติดตู้
เย็น
เสร็จแล้วก็เปิดตู้เย็นเอาโค้กมาเอาเย็น
เนสดื่ม
ใจ
through  a ไม่ดื่มโค้กกูเองดื่มน้ำ
น้ำเปล่าน้ำเปล่าถ้าใช่เย็นไหมคะไม่เย็น
ไม่เย็นไม่เย็นครูเอ๋
ธรรมดาไม่ดื่มน้ำเย็นๆ
เกมน้ำธรรมดานะคะแล้วก็ดื่มน้ำ
ร้อน
น้ำ
มีแก้ว
แก้วเราก็น้ำน้ำอุ่นค่ะน้ำอุ่น
องศาเซลเซียสเอสพี่ขอน้ำตาล 10
30 องศาคิดเป็นน้ำอุ่นคิดว่าเพราะว่าจะ
มีน้ำใช่มั้ยน้ำน้ำจากที่นี่
จากกระติกน้ำร้อน
ประมาณที่นี่ประมาณ 80 เนาะ
80 องศาเซลเซียสอ่ะอ่ะใส่แล้วก็น้ำอัน
นี้ใส่ก็ประมาณสามสิบแล้วก็ดื่มโอเค
ขอถ้าปู
80 องศา
น้ำร้อนน้ำร้อนดื่มไม่ได้
หน้าหรือไม่ได้ถามสิทธิ์น้ำอุ่นโอเคโอเค
ง่ายแต่ถ้าแบบนี้เราก็บอกน้ำธรรมดา
น้ำธรรมดาธรรมดา
ก็ไม่เห็นไม่เย็นไม่เย็นแต่ถ้าน้ำน้ำ
เนี่ยอยู่ใน
ตู้เย็น
น้ำเย็นอาหารงูเย็น
น้ำธรรมดา
น้ำขุ่นนะง่วงชอบดื่มแล้วครูเอ๋ชอบดื่ม
กาแฟไหมคะกาแฟครูเอ๋ไม่ดื่มกาแฟ
นานๆกูเอนดื่มกาแฟแล้วจุ๊บๆจุ๊บๆ
เหนื่อย
นอนไม่ได้นอนอ่ะ
ตา
ดื่มกาแฟไม่ได้ครูเรียมดื่มกาแฟไหมคะอ่ะ
มาเรียมดื่มกาแฟไม่ได้หัวใจก็จะเต้นเด็กๆ
เด็กๆเหมือนกับครูเอ๋
เหมือนกับครูอ้อครูเรียมเนี่ยกับครูเอ๋
เกิดเหมือนกันนะลิง
สองคนลิง
แล้วก็ดื่มกาแฟไม่ได้เหมือนกัน
ครูเรียมคูเรียมดื่มชาได้ไหมคะถ้าได้ค่ะ
ช้าเตรียมชอบชอบดื่มชา
อันนี้เป็นชาญี่ปุ่นนะคะๆเราก็มีชา
ญี่ปุ่นชาไทยชาจีนหวู่
ชาติไทย
ถ้าตัวเองไม่รู้วันนี้ชาย
อ๋อ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบดื่มชาใช่ไหมคะให้ครูเอ๋
ชอบดื่มทาอาอาอ้าแม้แต่คู่เอกก็นอนไม่ได้
ทำไม
เออไม่รู้ถ้าดื่มชา
ถ้าเป็น
ชายตา
ชะม้อย
ที่ที่ไม่ใช่ชา
อันนี้อันนี้ใบชาใช่ไหมไปวะนาถ้าใบชาอัน
นี้คุณดื่มก็นอนไม่ได้แต่ชอบๆๆๆแต่ถ้า
เป็นชาชาวป่ะคล้ายชา
The  heat  h5 พีชชาเดี๋ยวกูเอามาให้กู
เหลี่ยมดูถ้ามะลิ
จะถ่ายดอกไม้
นี่
หาก
ป่าวค่ะไทยค่ะ
ฉ่า
เห็นไหมอ่ะเห็นไหมอ่ะไม่ค่อยเห็นเห็นค่ะ
ฮอดมาก
งาน
ดอกไม้อ่ะแอปก็อะไรนะเอ้ามันตุ๊ด
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็ได้กูออกเสียงถูกไหมออสมันตุส
ขอหมื่นลี่ภาษาไทย
หอมอันนี้โอเคอ่าหมอทำโอนี่นายโอเค
her เวนเดอร์โอเค
เหงาได้แบบชาชานิของสามีโคเอนดื่มได้นิด
หน่อย
ผู้เรียนชอบไหม
ชอบค่ะชอบกินเขียวคูเรียมดื่มชาเขียวโอเค
มั้ยโอเคค่ะตึกๆ
ไหว้ค่ะขัวใจโอเคโอเคค่ะหัวใจโอเคแต่กาแฟ
ไม่ได้ดื่มได้
แล้วก็กูเอกชอบชอบตื่นอะไรอุ้ยตัวเองรัก
มีน้ำมีชาหอมหมื่นลี้อะ
มีโซดาเฮ้ย
เป็นยังไงไม่เคยดูก็คือมีกีวีร่วง
กูเอกชอบซุ่ม Soda
มาย
ก็เอาเอาโซดามาใส่กับส้มอาหารใต้ส้มเป็น
ยังไงคะคุณต้ม
สั้นๆ
ส้มๆบีบนะไม่เอาส้มแล้วสดๆ
ต้องต้องหันส้มแล้วก็บีบ
บีบบีบ of  K ค่ะคิดนี่
ชีวิตสุดาเอางี้ใส่แล้วเอาโซดาใส
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าต้องเอาเนื้อเขียวๆขึ้นมา
ใช่ไม่ได้ปั่นนะคะปั่นไหม
ปิดเครื่องปั่นถ้า
ไม่หาเรียงไม่ได้ปั่นค่ะจะเป็นกีวี่แล้ว
ก็ใส่โซดากีวีแบบนี้ค่ะหันๆเป็นชิ้นเล็กๆ
เราก็ใส่ในแก้ว
ชีวิตสีเขียว
ใส่ลงไปในแก้ว
ใส่น้ำแข็ง
[เพลง]
แต่น้ำแข็ง
กูลืมว่าสวยว่าคุยนะ
แล้วก็ใส่โซดา
ใส่สะระแหน่มั้ย
จะใจค่ะอันนี้ Soda ที่แบบมีฟองค่ะ
Soda แล้วก็ใส่ใบสะระแหน่สะระแหน่แพนั่ง
เรียนรู้จักสะระแนไหมอ่ะรอ
เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวกู a หารูปให้สะระแหน่
5 กูเอกเจอสะระแหน่แล้วค่ะคุณเรียม
เดี๋ยวนะตัวเองแชร์ให้ดู
อันนี้ค่ะครูเรียมสาระแนเห็นไหมอ๋อเห็น
ค่ะ
สาระแนนอ๋อของครูเรียมก็ใส่สะระแหน่ด้วย
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะใส่สะระแหน่ที่คนเดียว
อาหารเช้าบ้านครุย
น่ากินนอนแล้วก็ตื่นมากินไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋กิน
สามี Kids
Fair โอ้น้ามะนาวแล้วก็ผลไม้แล้วก็สลับ
น่ากินข้างข้างๆอะโวคาโดคืออะไร
น้อยหน่าน้อยหน่า
พี่น้อยหน่า
อ๋อ
น้อยนาให้ดูนิดนึง
น้อยหน่า
น้อ
ปิดเนาะอ่ะ
กูเรียมใส่อะไรบ้างนะใส่เกรวี่ใส่น้ำแข็ง
ใช่ค่ะไก่
สะระแหน่ได้สละแนนโชว์ดา
อร่อยมากแต่ว่าวันนี้วันนี้เตรียมอย่าง
ดื่ม
ชาไข่มุก
ถ้าใครโม้ว่าใครหมูอ๋อ
ครูเรียนจะจะออกไปนะคะครูเลี่ยมกินน้ำส้ม
ดีกว่าไหมน้ำส้มตัวมันเองพันธุ์คู๋มี
เครื่องปั่นเดี๋ยวกูเอาเอาส้มเนี่ยใส่
แล้วก็ปั่นให้
คู่ต้อง
ปั่นแบบนั้นไม่ได้ไม่ได้หรอไม่ได้ทำไมอ่ะ
คุยต้องขบขันน้ำขอคุยต้องทำงามต้องอ๋ออ๋อ
ใส่ส้ม 1 ลูกใส่แล้วปั่นไม่ได้อยู่ได้ขอ
พระเอกป้องต้องหันแล้วก็บีบใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
กูอีกแกะอ่ะแกะเฉยๆได้ไหมแกะต้ม
มันจะมีเมล็ดนะคะคู่เอก
เดี๋ยวนะกูเอกแกะให้ดู
หน้าแกะส้ม
อุ้ยอ๋อ
ไว้ที่ไหนดีไว้ที่นี่ออก
ถ้าไม่มี
อุ้ยน้ำส้มน้ำส้มไหลมีเม็ดเมล็ดข้างในมี
Made  of ปั่นไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะอ๋อต้องเอา
ออกโอเคใช่แล้วใส่
สายใช่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยว
เสียงมันมีมันมีน้ำอ้ะมันเลอะอ่ะครูเอ๋
กินส้มนะขอโทษค่ะนักเรียน
กินค่ะกินเลย
หวานนาค
[เพลง]
หิวน้ำหายแล้ว
เราพูดถึงเราพูดถึง
กาแฟกาแฟกาแฟร้อนกาแฟร้อนกาแฟร้อนค่ะแล้ว
ก็มีอะไรร้านกาแฟเอ็นน่ะ
น้ำแข็งเครื่องดื่มใช่น้ำแข็งมีน้ำแข็งมี
แก้วอะไรแอร์ร้อนได้เป็นถ้วยนะคะนักเรียน
พูดว่าถ้วยน่ะกาแฟหนึ่งถ้วย
กาแฟเย็นอ่ะโค้กเป๊ปซี่ 1 แก้วชัยหาแก้ว
แก้ว
แล้วอันนี้นะคะ
น้ำปั่นไหมน้ำปั่นค่ะน้ำนะมีเครื่องปั่น
ใช่ไหมอะไรค่ะเครื่องปั่นแล้วก็ใส่ให้ครู
เอมีรูปน้ำปั่นให้ครูเรียมดูอยากดูไหม
อย่าค่ะ
อยากดูอยากดูใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอะไร
ok ขอหาก่อนนะผู้เตรียมนี่อะกูเรียนยัง
ไม่เจอน้ำปั่นน่ะถ้าเจอหน้าแล้วผู้น้ำ
เต้าหู้น้ำเต้าหู้เลียมดื่มไหมคะดื่มค่ะ
เรียมดื่มน้ำเต้าหู้อันนี้ครูเอ๋ทำ
งู
น้ำเต้าหู้มีน้ำอื่นอีกไหม
นะทำไมไปไม่ได้
อยู่นี่อันนี้ก็น้ำเต้าหู้ค่ะข้อ
มือครูเอ๋โกเอ๋ทำให้ใช่มั้ยใช่สิไม่ใช่
เหมือนครูเอ๋ขอโทษมือหลานขาย
แก้วน้ำดูเล็บแล้วก็ไม่ใช่เล็บครูเอ๋
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะนี่น้ำปั่น
น้ำอะไรปนะคะมีสะระแหน่
มะนาว
อ่ะสับปะรด
แล้วก็ก็อันนี้น่าจะเป็นเมล่อนค่ะเมล่อน
แล้วก็กลับชายนะกลับไม้ใส่แล้วก็ใส่
เครื่องปั่นเอาใส่เครื่องปรับก็
[เพลง]
ว้าวมีอีกค่ะอุ้ย
ก่อนอันนี้อันนี้นะเป็นน้ำอันนี้ค่ะครู
โคเรียมมีองุ่น
งูอะระแนนมันละละ
ผมมาคง
แครอทนะๆอ้ะแต่งกวา
วันนี้อะไรคุยกับจะไม่ได้อะไรค่ะน่าจะ
หน่อสับปะรดอ่ะสับปะรด
กี่วีแล้วก็ผักนะคะคุณนะที่มีสระอะนะก็
ใส่แล้วก็ปันค่ะก็จะเป็นอันนี้ค่ะคุณ
เรียมถ้วยนี้
นาวหัดกับผลไม้อ้อมีอันนี้ด้วยมะเขือเทศ
มะเขือเทศปั่นหรือเปล่าวันนี้คุณเดียวน่า
จะชอบ
ใช่ค่ะ
เชอรี่เชอรี่สตรอเบอรี่สับปะรด
น้ำปั่นคูเรียมชอบน้ำปั่นใช่ค่ะเตรียมชอบ
เบอร์ลี่ปัดขอเบอร์รี่ทั้งหมดแล้วคุณเอ๋
มีไหมอ่ะหมดแล้วกูเองไม่มี
ไม่มีมิกซ์เบอร์รี่นะคะอ่าอันนี้เป็น
สับปะรดกับแอปอ่า
เห้ย
กูเลี้ยงแต่คู่เรียนบอกจะกินชาไข่มุกใช่
ค่ะวันนี้เตรียมอยากดื่มชาไข่มุกมั้ยดื่ม
น้ำปั่นไหว้ค่ะมายงั้นก็ก็ oku เลียมหิว
น้ำอยากดื่มทานนมไข่มุกงั้นต้องให้ครู
เรียมไปแล้วนะคะใช่ค่ะคู่เลี้ยวถึงไหมคะ
ผู้อารมณ์ไข่มุกไม่ดื่มสาร
ครูเออายุ 53
ดื่มชานมไข่มุกไม่ดี
เออครูเรียมเด็กๆดื่มชานมไข่มุกโอเคโอเค
อร่อยดื่มน้ำเปล่าดื่มน้ำตั้งค่ากาเขียว
หมูแล้วก็ดื่มน้ำส้มอ๋อ
โอเคเอ้านักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียน
ชอบชานมไข่มุกไหม
นักเรียนชอบน้องไข่มุก
ทุเรียนครูเอ๋อยากรู้นักเรียนทีมครูเรียม
หรือทีมครูเอ๋ธีมโคเรียมดื่มชานมไข่มุก
ดื่มโค้กมาอาอาอิอีอุอูเอดื่มน้ำเปล่า
น้ำส้ม
อันนี้สองคนเดิมแล้วมันน้ำปั่นมาเนอะ
อยากรู้ไหมคะ
อยากรู้ค่ะ
นักเรียนเขียนคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะนักเรียน
ชอบดื่มอะไรและ
มหาศาลใจค่ะขาสำหรับคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กับครู
เรียมไปก่อนนะคะ
หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะหมดแล้วเลยอีกแล้ว
คุณก่อนไปนักเรียนดูฟังแล้วทำอะไรคะ 1
กด
ไลค์ 5  2 กด
Subscribe
R3 กดแชร์
ปี่กด
สั่นกระดิ่งค่าสั่นกระดิ่งแล้วก็แห้ง
คอมเม้นให้เรารู้ด้วยนักเรียนดื่มอะไรนะ
คะไทยค่ะช่อแล้วดื่มอะไร
ใจค่ะแล้วเจอกับครูเอ๋และมาเรียมในคลิป
หน้านะคะค่าบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนม
[เพลง]